des centaines et des centaines de pommes
de terre du nord pour les verrières wade
sac de 15 kg vendu 5 euros à prix
coûtant une vente sur la journée
organisée à travers un système de drive
sur le parking du scarabée 15 kg ch et
accessible pour les grandes familles les
nombreuses lettres pas mal d'enfants et
c'est pas mal c'est pas moi je sais pas
cherché bénéfique pour tout le monde
généralement ils fournissent beaucoup
les restaurations les restaurateurs là
il se retrouve avec
une production sur les bras donc au lieu
de laisser sa dépérir et ben non ça nous
arrange eux ça les arrange ce type
d'opération une habitude pour ce
producteur depuis le déconfinement au
mois de mai 2020 plus de 300 tonnes de
pommes de terre ont été vendus ou donnés
à des associations
ce jour là ils sont venus avec 28 en
charge et dans ce camion pour éviter
justement de jeter cette nourriture
nous avons décidé de prendre des camions
et de venir en ile de france on vend ses
pommes de terre
5 euros les 15 kg ce qui nous permet de
couvrir nos frais et couvrir les frais
de transport et de faire profiter de
produits français de qualité
justement aux consommateurs
un fils de france pour la mairie de la
verrière c'est l'occasion de mettre à
disposition des habitants des produits
agricoles français mais pas seulement
il y aurait également un don qui sera
fait à des associations caritatives
ce type d'opérations de vente directe va
effectivement s'intensifier avec
d'autres producteurs il faut qu'on
travaille plus intensément sur cette
dimension
prochain rendez vous pour le producteur
de pommes de terre du nord le jeudi 3
décembre à trappes sur la place des
merisiers